une augmentation des effectifs dans les
services d'urgence au niveau national
une reconnaissance salariale du
personnel principalement sur ces deux
points là et bien sûr sur la qualité de
la prise en charge dans son ensemble
actuellement il ya quatre postes à
pouvoir d'affirmer aux urgences de
besançon la direction a du mal à trouver
du personnel
les gens ne veulent plus venir à cause
des conditions de travail c'est ce qu'on
nous dit les gens qui viennent au bout
de deux mois repartent parce que le
travail est trop dure que la qualité de
prise en charge est tellement dégradée
que c'est invivable pour les personnels
sol en la sécurité des patients n'est
pas en danger
pendant la grève et en dehors de la
grève les patients sont en sécurité
mais la qualité des soins n'est plus au
rendez vous depuis de nombreuses années
étant encore à se dégrader